les élections législatives 2022
signe-t-elle la fin des républicains
dans les yvelines pour un département
qui vote traditionnellement à droite
aucun candidat n'est qualifié pour le
second tour ils arrivent tous au pied du
podium en 3e voire en quatrième position
pour certains ça sincèrement je crois
que c'est une très grande déception que
nous pouvons
avoir par rapport au résultat d'hier je
pensais encore une fois pour connaître
le terrain pour être sur le terrain que
nos territoires et est encore restée à
droite j'ai vécu l'élection
départementale elle est dernière où la
droite était encore forte ça n'est pas
aujourd'hui ce qui ce qui pouvait être
quand on regarde on prendra le temps
d'analyser un petit peu les chiffres
qu'on a on a fait un bon score sur la
rassure la droite c'est vrai que ça a
été éparpillés avec un vote que moi je
n'attendais pas forcément aussi fort de
l'extrême droite à la fois reconquête
sur des vignes comme le chesnay ou
où le fn enfin le rassemblement national
survie de l'époque bill preuve nos jours
et qu'ils font un très bon score ce qui
est tout à fait inhabituelle dans la 11e
circonscription le député sortant depuis
2020 philippe benassaya et évincé
l'ancien maire de bois d'arcy fini en
troisième position avec 18% autre député
sortant dans la 8e circonscription
michel vialay en 2017 c'est le seul
républicain a accédé à l'assemblée
nationale 2022 renversement de tendance
michel vialay se retrouve en quatrième
position avec 7,85 % des voix seulement
c'est regrettable parce que quand vous
voyez l'investissement qu'a pu avoir
philippe et la saga ou même de michel
gallet mais c'est votre département tf1
c'est quand même incroyable parce que
les autres députés très sincèrement on
l'est on les voit quand même très peu
aussi on les a vu très peu dans la
première dans la mandature précédente
autre bouleversement pour la droite dans
la première circonscription pour la
première fois depuis plus de 30 ans elle
n'est pas présente au second tour des
élections législatives
la dynamique nationale a pris le dessus
par rapport à l'ancrage local deuxième à
conflans derrière l'union de la gauche
et troisième au niveau de la
circonscription je ne serai pas au
second tour des élections législatives
les vagues nationale était trop forte et
ont pris le pas sur le local je tiens à
remercier les électeurs qui ont voté
pour moi après la défaite de la droite
aux présidentielles avec un score de
valérie pécresse à 4 78% la désillusion
se poursuit aux législatives où elle
recueille 13,17 % des voix